as this is ignition plate this is
another flame princess episode of she's
in the beginning in the end that's about
it and they're just having fun
lighting their farts and burps on fire
and about it jiggaman just starts to
reek so they try to get some scented
candles from from a room which I just
realized there's no other places that
have scented candles they had to travel
all the way to the fire Kingdom
no she wanted hers okay she was she was
saying how she misses you know her
scented candles and it was finished said
Oh we'll go get them for you okay
you don't remember this we've watched it
a minute ago you know in an Adventure
Time episode could you make the argument
that a lot of crazy happens and
that maybe it's hard to keep track of it
because it's all so crazy no you should
remember everything now that says
sentence and phrase ever what that says
episode is not specially crazy I was
gonna be a lot crazier but it's it's
it's fun it's good they go to try and
get the scented candles and they hear
this plot about these two they're gonna
try and kill kill the king so with a
nice slice so they try to go and
discover who it is and I was half right
I said I bet they're just rehearsing for
a play but then they use a play to
figure out who did it which I get okay
and that in no way makes me write the
more I think about it but still um least
I can admit when I'm wrong I I just
admitted it I just and I didn't have to
I didn't have to say hey I had a theory
but here's how it's wrong you see I
could have just left that all out but no
stop being distracted by the cat stop it
it's Tim's getting above it he's too
precious so anyway sorry folks
it's a cat it's a cute cat okay so
anyway yeah you better run so when so
they go and they tried to figure out who
it is and they act at the scene you know
a la Hamlet and find out who the killers
are and pretty much he discovers that
everybody in the fight is it fire
yeah okay um very less fire kingdom or
flame Kingdom because they're all it
like it's flame I don't fire nation I
got there Oh before anyone's like I you
idiot so fire nation which one's fire
nation Fire Nation is Avatar so so yeah
so they they figure out that everyone
there is evil and they're like well does
that make Flame Princess evolving like
now he says well can if a good guy comes
around candy changer to not evil it's
like I suppose and well okay okay you're
destroying a great reference there so
she's kid is she chaotic neutral yeah I
I know what she would it wouldn't make
correct chaotic neutral well I mean that
would cause some penalties to her
basically a D&D reference okay I never
played the indie I know I can tell but
now I know what that is and I guess
that's funnier um but what no but I like
about that ending is that they're
building it up like it's gonna be this
big thing where he's gonna go yeah leave
that's what you're good at but you're so
good at so they're building up
descending like you know the flame king
is gonna like you know a turn to good
hmm and you see him get like really
upset and you think it's gonna lead to
something really big are you throwing
ice at me is it working is it killing
you I say no it's just making make your
cold but I'm so glad you got to see that
so he appears in these in the scented
candles now rather than doing anything
me just goes yeah that's pretty much the
episode it's I love the fire Kingdom I
love I actually would this one you
really get to see more the designs of
the people and the different kind of
fire clothes they and I'm like the maths
and stuff and the three little guys
though three little guys that love their
snacks the Fanta Jake disguising
themselves as the painting was great so
there's definitely funny moments I
I guess like here you going to the fire
kingdom it's like ooh you know like
let's see more of that Kingdom but you
know we're sort of stuck in the castle
and the castle is not phenomenally
interesting but again when you're in the
theater you get to see more of those
fire people I love the design of those
fire people Oh
32 oh yeah I get maybe this one was just
like even for me I'm just like okay
that's just one reason why I loved it to
see just how messed up the like there
came to me yeah they just do nothing of
value everything is completely pointless
oh you know and I guess just cuz they're
so evil it's like you know wait you say
you kill good dance yeah so everyone
here is evil just evil and they're just
they're all evil but they're all kind of
poor great size of the cakes that they
eat so that's that's such a little
funnier the more I think about it just
that the fire keep in this big evil
terrible place it's like they're all
really boring and not insurance well I
love the part where they drop into the
blueberries and the chef says I'm gonna
kill you big I'm gonna chop you big
blueberries into little blueberries
after finding out that the for a wild
finish had a snake on his shoulder yeah
I'm not I'm not saying a history just
I'm it's making her soldier their
shoulder oh and then Finn and Jake take
to the gut to the actors I'm sorry I'm
sorry I'm sorry take their clothes and
walk off the chef goes in there and sees
them in the weirdest position you could
probably be in like tied to a table with
food everywhere it's just like actors I
don't think you know actors though
that's that's probably what you'd say to
half the people you've seen at cons and
stuff if you saw in that position
wouldn't you just be like Oh Malcolm
McDowell Oh
Metsu project yeah together tied to a
table that's just what they call
Wednesday yeah good point so as I just
be like oh Matthew Broderick and Malcolm
McDowell tied to a table Wednesday it
can't come soon enough in the week
so how do you talk after that let's see
let's bring up some things that people
are gonna yell at us because we didn't
bring up people have a tendency to say I
can't believe you forgot about this well
you people have to understand this we
literally watch the episode right before
we record this no there's a great
pressure can our hands but there's no
script
we don't think now it's you know so when
we forget stuff it's not that we're just
ignoring it it's that we get distracted
and we're kind of foolish should we do
not we do not get yeah there's no cat
even there he's why I can't distraction
by nothing that's how distracted I yeah
so don't like that's why I'm saying
let's actually think about stuff we may
have forgotten that there's not really
much yeah I was gonna say this is not
like it's an okay episode it's a decent
one I think anything with like is I
don't know with that whole set up I
guess on the one hand I respect the joke
if that they are all really boring and
they're just evil and they're bound is
mundane not interesting as you can get
but on the other hand it's like I want
them to be interesting I don't know this
is working too well or if it's working
just right I don't know but I did like
the theater guy they go and they talk to
these fins like what's going on here and
the theater guy explains it it goes but
being from the same acting troupe you
know all this already but like so many
shows they have oh I'm gonna act like
some blank guard and there's like
so what are we guarding here I they say
exactly what it is no one ever questions
are you or no one even has to ask
they're just like you know so you
excited about the big event where yadda
yadda yadda and they just say all the
stuff and this one it's it's self-aware
enough where he's like oh whoa but you
would already know that because yeah I
love just how normal people talk so yeah
it's it's funny it's a cute episode I
could use a few more laughs but like I
said make me the joke is that there's
not it's just how boring they are pretty
much yeah when your boredom I did love
the guy who's in the odd cause what I
love is is that Jake is like okay what
we're gonna do
act out exactly what we heard and we're
going to pay attention to everyone in
the audience and we're gonna figure out
who did it my idea I came up with it
from nowhere else yeah so if they're up
there and they're performing the guys
huh - yeah I like it then the second
time snacks yes yes yes did you notice
how they walk backwards yes the entire
time they're always walking backwards
the entire tango even when you first see
it if I remember right yeah they're all
walking backwards you sure I remember
right it can be wrong now that they're
walking forwards but you just always see
the front of their faces like they're
walking towards them I okay is this
picture dude I thought maybe no you
can't if there's anything the Internet
has taught us is we can never be wrong
but we can blame people do you want to
bring up with the last episode also was
this episode was was it thunderous was a
Naruto